given that retrieval is an important
part of developing long-term memory so
then some might argue we should be doing
tests to force us to retrieve things
that we have learned however when we are
listening and reading covering a lot of
different types of material maybe some
of the same essential subject matter
using different books or different
sources we are in fact forcing ourselves
to retrieve things that we have in our
memory so we don't have to have a
deliberate retrieval practice or
exercise that is going to force us to
retrieve things by the mere fact that we
are reading and listening to things we
are again retrieving them so that the
exercise of retrieving takes place
naturally in an input-based learning
style